all right here's the pharmacy of
Microsoft who is now the founder of USA
facts and the chairman of the LA
Clippers Steve Ballmer's you you bounded
out here just the way I thought you
would with a little energy oh my god you
are a bull of energy where do you get
this energy Steve what are you smoking
can you share someone I even got up that
caffeine stop I'm all Lacroix all the
time all right
so yes I love what you're doing this us
a fax thing right and tell the people
what it is because it sort of inherently
anti-trump because it's about facts well
we started I started about four years
ago my wife said I'd retired she said
it's time to get involved
philanthropically and you know we're
focused on kids and kids in need I said
all we need to do is pay our taxes let's
be good tax payers government takes care
of that and she said dude come on we can
do better than that right but it got me
to say I wonder really where the tax
dollars come from and where they go so
I'm just the facts right people will
like scroll through a hundred Yelp
reviews to find a taco stand but they
have no idea where their tax dollars go
and you you did you did a deep dive
like a businessman cuz you you were the
head of Microsoft you're a businessman
should I at least ought to read stuff
that's as good I can read about any fun
find out where the money's going what
it's doing what the outcome is and then
and give us some examples like
healthcare take health care since 1980
health care per person inflation
adjusted is up two hundred twenty five
percent two hundred and twenty five
percent okay let's take a look people
like to talk about life expectancy I'm
not a life expectancy guy that's
forecasts and futures I just look at the
average age at which people die that
seems to be about actuals not work as if
you're never gonna die nothing can kill
this right okay this is put in the last
twenty years average age at which people
got died is gone from seventy two point
three years to seventy two point nine
years Wow that's it for all the money
we're just hemorrhaging into healthcare
you think we'd be buying people extra
life but obesity's up a lot of these
other factors so are we spending our
health care dollars well I'll leave it
to you to decide well we need health
care dollars I think a lot because we
eat [ __ ] and we breathe [ __ ] exactly if
we like we had a healthier environment
to live in the tax bill would I mean
that health care bill would go way down
you've also studied the environment
right absolutely I mean the amount of
disasters as we're seeing another storm
this week right isn't hasn't that like
way jumped natural disaster declarations
over the last ten years or so have
jumped in fact and it's interesting you
can actually say what does what's caused
it but you can see things that are going
on you can look at the climate data I'm
kind of a science oriented guy all right
tell you that at USA facts we're not
partisan
we're not partisan out on the issues and
that's why do the data it's great
because the biggest the second you take
aside people are gonna then in this
tribal atmosphere say oh I don't believe
it even though it's a fact so that's
great you're just putting it out there
we'll take government writers will show
you what they are I mean you can take a
look at the border thing border agents
are up right
prehension sir down undocumented
immigrant estimates are flat well you
have to decide how you think about it we
can't tell you right we'll just give you
the numbers so what about education are
our children reading gooder per student
has about doubled over the clap again
inflation adjusted over the last 30
years or so about double and yet still
only about a third of our kids third
grade level can read at grade level are
proficient and third grade reading a
third of kids and yet we have doubled
spend speaking of spending let me ask
you this I read the other day that you
are worth forty three billion dollars is
that the number well it's of course when
you have that much you're not getting
the checkbook at the end of the month I
[Laughter]
think Chris Farley died did went into
you
but but I mean does anyone need forty
billion dollars not to live uh but
should anybody have forty billion
dollars FDR once proposed not just a
minimum wage but a maximum wage yeah
it's it's an interesting should anybody
have it no in our case will we have it
no we're trying to give away the money
focused again on kids in poverty as much
as we sensibly can you can live on a
billion right yeah yeah you can't push
the Clippers I get to keep the clip oh
absolutely you don't need it but the
question is can you do it well with okay
but like I always base money on like how
might what percentage of your money you
know like when I started I would do any
job for thirty dollars
I I did told jokes and bars with no
stage with sawdust on the floor now they
can offer me a lot not your kind of
money but and I won't do it because it's
in day of my life I don't want to go
someplace and talk to corporate [ __ ]
I don't care how much you pay me you
can't buy a day at the age of 62 so what
I'm saying Steve is I just gave a
million dollars to the Democrats God to
me that's a lot of money because I think
the most important thing to do in the
world right now is get rid of Donald
Trump or at least check him but it seems
to me because like even though that's a
lot of money won't change my life I
won't have to drive an uber I don't have
expensive hobbies I'm not one of those
dumbass celebrities who has you know
[ __ ] let's not go into it
[Applause]
but it seems like you could win this
election by yourself and not feel it
[Applause]
that's about the most unethical thing
you could possibly do for yourself you
don't think turning an election is an
ethical thing to do when the person
you're running against is drum then you
get into the question of you know how
you think about things no for my morals
no I'm not buying elections I'm just not
doing it okay I try